here's the thing he won by thirty three
thousand i'm just gonna say that can i
can i just give you like a little layup
here but
nikki at one point said this is a purple
state that there's half the state it
agrees with him
it's still perfect 100 by the way 100
okay we'll see and by the way the i4
corridor is basically what splits the
state yes or no yes okay you've got a
lot of red in this state right now yeah
that's the i4 coordinator i mean i think
you have letting you know it's a purple
state do your research got you
however
that flip though you guys got two more
on the republican side
it's trending the different way no no no
it's historic say it correctly though
because that's what happened based on
data
republicans picked up two more so it
flipped that's what happened to florida
but continually and we could go into
holding that happening
that's just no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
that's what's what's happened yeah with
the right trending you may not like it
but that's what's happening
because of desantis continue but she
does have a point that half the state
thought certain way have to state now if
you want to say no it's 55 45 cool
whatever but they're even 60 40. cool
whatever
but my question to you is though
the race that desantis won in 2018 i
believe very close neck and neck with
andrew gillum yep so my question to you
is all right desantis won
clearly
there's some advocacy for him
what would be different if andrew gillum
won like desantis came in people are
flocking
could a case be made that that wouldn't
have been the case with gillum like
give desantis maybe a little bit of
credit here like what would be different
if gillum was the governor versus
desantis yeah i i think that what would
have happened differently is that you
would not have had this cultural
division that you wouldn't have had a
governor who only thought that he was
only right and did not listen to other
viewpoints and that is what democracy is
supposed to be about that you're
supposed to have people on both sides of
the aisle that are supposed to come
together and make decisions that are for
the best interests of our state what and
it doesn't happen in any state i'm going
to be honest with you but that has never
happened in new york i mean i i got to
vote in new york
that's how you just got here this is how
florida used to be
this florida used to be that way i used
to be able to charlie crist
i mean i talked to bob graham all the
time she does have a point here we all
used to i talked to jeb all the time i'm
student body president during time of
jebs and i talk to jeb all the time i
still talk to rick scott all the time
during some of this pandemic stuff rick
was calling me and i was calling him
that's what it's supposed to be about in
fact i was in washington dc last week
and i was talking to my federal affairs
director and marco calls our office to
work with us all the time rubio yeah
that that is what it's supposed to be
about and i was duly elected flipping a
seat by a million votes i hear what
you're saying
and there's no there's no coming
together and the recognition you won by
thirty three thousand there's dif
there's how many total people voted
eight point three million didn't eight
million people vote free and you only
won by 6 753 votes and that's why i
talked to republicans all day long yeah
but you also barely won that is correct
okay so what's the point the point is
that i flipped a seat by almost a
million votes a democrat hasn't won
commissioner of agriculture in over 20
years no female has ever won
commissioner of agriculture i recognized
that i didn't win by a hundred thousand
five hundred thousand and so you know
what i did my first legislative session
all of my pieces of legislation were
sponsored by republicans
i'm going to tell you though that and i
hear what you're saying about wanting
people to come together and i i lived in
that head for a very long time and i'll
tell you when it flipped from me
it flipped for me when the mandates
happened and i realized that there were
people on the other side of the aisle
that wanted that would take that would
bury me in five seconds if they had the
chance that is not regardless that is
not what's happening in this moment
because there's a big segment of the
country there's two big segments of the
country on both sides sides of the aisle
who feel very differently i mean you
talk about gun control you can talk
about crime you can talk about the
police you can every issue
it's two different worlds two different
ways of thinking it's going to be very
hard and those people you're talking
about i mean jeb bush he doesn't appeal
to me as a conservative marco rubio
right now doesn't appeal to me a
conservative i'm looking at the rand
pauls of the world i'm looking at the
ron desantis of the world
conservatives people on the right and
people who are center-right are very
drawn to these fighters
people who aren't going to sit down and
say well i'll give a little and you give
a little because that little that they
give away is damaging but that's what
democracy is supposed to be we're not
we're a republic we're not even a
democracy truthfully but
great that sounds great that's that
sounds beautiful on paper but when it
comes down to it people right now are in
a moment where they're like i need to
take care of my family my kids they've
just got that hell in some places like
you've just seen a compromise but that's
what you're describing is what's wrong
with america right now okay that right
now because that's not how it used to be
i have a master's in political
campaigning i have a master's from you
have a degree in politics
and every time
every time i have been involved besides
when this went south with desantis i
told you that we started this
conversation i walked into a cabinet
that i had been friends with ashley
moody since underground in law school
i've known jimmy patronis since his time
in the legislature i walked in as the
head of the democratic party saying
let's find things that we can work
together on whether it's the environment
whether support for the state of israel
whatever it is
that we tried to work on compromise and
the first legislative session all of my
bills were sponsored by republicans
and that they're what kind of
republicans though the mitch mcconnells
of the world that drive me crazy the
people who don't dig in their heels and
fight
this is what i'm saying but if you and i
sat down right now and we say we were
trying to work together on something we
we might maybe the medical marijuana or
the marijuana legalization we would be
you guys should probably go smoke a
joint i'm just throwing that out
i've never smoked a joint well it's
starting now we're going to make some
changes
a pot brownie after the show but no
really i'm sure that issue but we would
have a really hard time because we
wouldn't
trying to go out tonight guys yeah he's
thinking miami it might get close to 4
20. that's all he's thinking about
that's a good point
watch us finish it
we would have a really hard time working
together in the sense of we may like
each other we may get along but i want
very different things for this country
and if i were running my platform would
look very different from yours
sounds like you're making a campaign
for something no but i i'm tired of of
politics as usual it seems like
politicians get into a room and they all
shake hands and they come out and it's
like
do any did you any of you fight did you
dig in
policy wise what are you saying that
you're wholeheartedly different from her
saying that i would be fighting for
school choice and i would be rallying
and even
i want people to i want that second
amendment upheld and protected i i want
i feel very strongly about that okay so
let's let's talk about those two issues
okay let's talk about what you just
talked about choice i'm not opposed to
choice
not a point it's a choice at all you
know in fact like i said i i've said
this also very publicly i had a learning
disability when i was growing up and
luckily i was in a school that it was
recognized and that i got special
attention to make sure that that
happened right and
so not every child fits into the
traditional school setting that's right
that that is see we're agreeing okay
but but i don't agree with taking money
away from our traditional schools to put
them in choice so you increase the
amount of education
and money going in there and i know
there's other i mean we can talk for
other hours about what yeah and we would
and i think that i think that this
presents itself as you know i hear what
you're saying you want people to come
together more you want you want you want
politics to be more palatable you know
in terms of it being i understand that
but that's not the moment we're in so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]